hey
we're live
we're doing it
on hot breath live
yeah yay
yeah i got a haircut for this so thank
you everyone for no i did no
so did yoshi yoshi and i both got here
for this for sure
what's happening what's goodie everyone
as we say here welcome to hot breath
live
wait a minute
where'd that come from
wait a minute surprise surprise surprise
surprise hey it's the man every once in
a while a man tried to take a brother
down there
we'll get into that i watched some of
sam j's show that we'll we'll talk about
today as well
uh so we're gonna get into that we have
a fun show for y'all today so welcome to
hot breath live
hey yay
i'm i'm comedian joel byers
and i am comedian yoshi so in the
building
and this is hot breath live everyone
woo
[Music]
playing that applause sound effect
you can applaud this at the house
let's get it dc rant said let's get
funny fam yeah we out here fam
i like that let's get funny that's what
we do we just get funny just get funny
in here this is our weekly live stream
where we give you joke feedback but also
give you
the working comedian's perspective of
the industry and we always
discuss some
topics
of uh that have the heat right now in
the comedy industry and try to give you
the working comics point of view not
some
news station click baity or
um famous comedians and what they think
we're giving you from the ground from
the front lines
[Applause]
i've heard that one oh but gary said hi
joel and yoshi good to see y'all in here
hello hello so as we come in here if you
have not subscribed to our youtube
channel yet go ahead and do that and
share this video right now
like right now
right now right right now right now as
we're talking
and we're about to get into today's
topics
go ahead and go ahead and subscribe to
the channel and go ahead and share this
video so other peeps can find us and
know how dope hot breath is i mean come
on fam
so
with that being said we're about to jump
into the show yoshi are you doing okay
my friend
i'm doing good brother um i have a
i'm doing world series this week in
florida
that's coming up um
tomorrow all weekend and then
uh prepping for my headlining set
happening at the end of the month in
dallas at dallas comedy club
baby let's go let's go
excited about that just you know working
out the kinks man you know how that is
when you got a big one you're like oh
you gotta take out the words gotta take
out them pauses gotta but sometimes if
you're headlining it's about adding
those in
sometimes it's like how do i fill 45
minutes again
[Music]
yeah the thing is
the jokes are there
it's like
how do i
stay in it like because i know that i
tend to go fast like you've told me
sometimes you just gotta slow down you
know just like and sort of let let the
audience kind of come to you rather than
just hitting the audience with like
joke joke joke kind of thing yeah for
sure yeah we're not all earthquake um
none of us are
actually
savage
he's coming up on every every show
he's gonna he's gonna be brought up um
oh uh jeff cohn said crush it at
mccurdy's yoshida that's what's up
jeff is awesome man i hope i said it is
did i say his last name right i'm sorry
perfect yeah thanks for hanging out jeff
when he was here in the atlanta show it
was awesome that's so cool
and uh were we in vegas we might have
been in another city together yeah jeff
is very doing world series
yeah at the world series
very nice thanks for hanging out jeff so
we are going to be giving joke feedback
throughout this show as well but
um we have a few topics to discuss that
is all must discuss
for
comedians out there and we were talking
before we want this to be kind of like
an extension or the feel of comics
talking on an open mic
and what comics that the open mic may be
talking about
yeah man
so
as we get into today's topics of
discussion my friends
the first up
someone had a new comedy special drop
today somebody
somebody had a little drop of the drop
drop on the neck
negative flip flips you know what i mean
netflix just dropped
cat williams special world war three and
cat williams to me when i saw it's
pimpin pimpin
you know because you know i got that
white boy joel atl slang type of thing
you know and it was really cat williams
it's pimpin pimpin
that really like just
gosh it's like sinbad made me want to do
comedy but then seeing kat williams and
just how hard he was killing and how
much swag he had with it
he he's he's been one of my favorite
sensing pimp and pimping and i've since
seen all of his specials but that was
the one that really set it off for me as
like oh this guy's another level
yeah yeah yeah that i would say uh that
one the pimp chronicles mm-hmm and the
great america are probably like my
favorite
and man he's just he's he's
he's such a beast
like he's got just he goes beast mode on
all his specials he just knows it super
entertaining
just like
talks about the toughest of topics which
i appreciate about cat um but does it
with such a swagger and just has his own
point of view on it as well so yeah he's
very uh the thing i enjoy about cat 2
and ahmed just said what's up so what's
up ahmed
what's up brother oh we got tavis in the
building as well good to see y'all in
here where are we at y'all who who out
you
comment with us in the live chat where
you at fam
but he um
what i like about kat williams
from a comedic perspective is
that
yeah he's flashy and yeah he can come
off kind of blingy i don't know how much
more white i could sound than saying
he's blingy
but like
he is very uh
he's very like poignant he he really
makes a lot of like very astute
observations and has very like refined
points of view that you see this guy in
like a pimp outfit and you're like wait
he's dropping bars about like
society and culture and mindset it's uh
i always loved that dichotomy about his
comedy for sure yeah yeah like he
that's what i appreciate about not only
his comedy but like i feel like his
audience is also very much like they're
in it they can take a tough topic or
they can take a very dirty
what i would say describe as sort of a
gutter topic just gutter material and
still be like in the same room still
enjoying the same type of comedy so
that's what i like i uh
in uh in the corporate world we call
that scale he scales he can
he knows like
everyone who started here and everyone
here and everyone to the side it's like
he just has a way of
figuring out like
people no matter where you are and i
don't mean like low high it's just like
he just has a very
sharp mind and that's impressive with
the comedian
for sure yeah and uh tavis said the new
special didn't have a super solid finish
but cat is a certified killer
oh yeah yeah yeah and we'll get into it
we uh
oh yeah and zeb is joining us we got a
few peeps joining us here zeb
from dayton tennessee i actually met up
with zeb this past weekend he was
hosting for dusty slay
comedy catch and uh we met up and had a
nice man brunch
which was nice
and then i had one of my you know yoshi
how i'll um i get real excited and then
i'll have an idea and then just throw it
out there without sleeping on it so then
i had a killer show
in uh in maryville tennessee feeling
myself and then i immediately texted zeb
and was like yo
we can because we were talking about
doing a show together where he could
feature because he wants to start
featuring and i was like yo my college
has a theater it holds a thousand people
i think we can sell it out and then
like just high on comedy and then i
haven't followed up with them yet about
it um but
yep
i was like so hyped i had such a killer
show i was like we're invincible
you need those you need those every once
in a while to feel like oh yeah i got
into this game for the right reasons
right
yeah yeah yeah for sure
so who knows it's not out of the
question yet but it was um
but um oh gary is from maryland jacob
says what's up fellas
that's what's up steve poger here what's
poppin steve oh we deep in this beast
so
the cat williams special you and i are
both working comedians we like to give
that perspective of comics that are on
the road that are grinding that are
building hours
um i've i've filmed my own self-produced
hour special you've produced your own
album as well so
we're both fans of cat williams you know
ever since the pimp and pimping days for
me but
this special world war three
i just kind of all of a sudden appeared
on netflix like there was no real promo
there was no like big epic trailer
i kind of stumbled upon it
like maybe late last week and then i'll
say oh cool cat's gonna have a special
and then
world war three here it is
yeah yeah yeah um i
i
i think
i started seeing it come up like a
couple of weeks ago
i think very cat williams like
cat isn't like a big promo type of
person anyway
and i think literally the promo for this
was him like in a hot tub
that was that was the introduction that
was the intro to the special so you had
no idea what there wasn't any you know
most intros it's like a little bit of a
joke a little tag something to get you
to be like oh that's going to be funny
when i see it kind of thing it was not
nothing you had no idea what the outfit
was going to be you saw nothing of the
special you were just hyped at that it
was kat williams
so i think
yeah
here he is at his uh in his hot tub
just
just being cat williams being uniquely
him which is one of my favorite parts
about him is just
he's always uniquely him and authentic
to him and his voice
and dude kat williams is one of the
nicest people
um in terms of like a comedian's comic
like
he showed up he has shown up in atlanta
and just like
we'll sit and just watch people
and that's just impressive he'll just
sit and like watch comics and if anybody
comes and talks to him he'll engage in a
conversation yeah for some of that level
like it's just impressive because you
just don't expect that because he is
kind of a big deal he's not a small deal
he's huge
and he he came to my show uh one time
but the show i used to host here in
atlanta before the building burned down
that i still claim it was not me just
for the record i feel like i have to say
that every time but
he came and just watched the show one
night and even gave all the comics
a couple hundred bucks he gave every
comic but me money so i don't know what
that means
he did come on stage with me and like he
took a photo and whatnot but he did not
give me any money he probably just
thought i didn't need it but yeah he saw
the complexion he's like you're probably
good he's like why boy white boy don't
need it i was like not homie i look
purebred but i'm in bread fam let me get
a let me get a sweet lick for some gas
money on the humbug
but
yeah so super nice guy i mean he
definitely has had his
controversies and he's very opinionated
but he's also authentic to
who he is as a comedian and who he is
and his voice and his perspective he
doesn't
try to bend for anyone or try to just
assimilate just for the sake of being
generic but he really is always
authentically cat which i appreciate and
this special i
i will
i will say half of it
um
i was on
i was on board for half of it like
gung-ho the first half yes this is
authentically cat he's making incredible
points
and he what i love about his comedy is
that
he can talk about complex issues and
topics
but make it very grounded make it very
just approachable
yes yeah yeah yeah um yeah like so
analytically so i counted the last
special okay
and there was 290 so right around like
300 300 laughs and it was a 57 minute
special so it's about five and a half
laps a minute technically right about
five to five and a half laps a minute
his speed and style
gave way to where a lot of the things
a lot of ways that he
was getting laughs i recognize is very
different than other people he got
laughs a lot on just like facial
expressions and physicality
where he didn't say anything and just
got laughed just by a certain look or by
a certain thing that he did on stage
which i thought was super impressive i
mean we kind of know that catboy was you
know
some of the stuff that he did in the
early days
the physical stuff was some of the most
hilarious things that you remember like
yeah
uh about his kid having a dd
um
was just the funniest thing his way his
kid ran he's like i just want to run
i don't know if you remember that which
special that was but it was just
hilarious just the physicality of this
kid running running like running from
this side and you see cat running from
this side
of the stage yeah yeah
and it was just good so like i really
like enjoy that part the other piece
like that i really found unique about
his approach
he repeats his points a lot throughout
higher special
like there was a couple things that he
said he was like
um what was it
lie versus truth lie versus truth lie
versus truth and you just
get repeated like over and over again
and just like there was just lots of
things even like when he's talking about
the chicken wing shortage which is a
great joke oh my
dude
that's why the second half let me down
because he was i was like oh he's going
all in here he's talking about
10 minutes that chicken wing joke was
about a 10 minute joke it was so funny
it was so funny chicken shortage of
chicken wings but not thought like
there's just
these obvious things like and not
chickens that likes obvious things yeah
he said taco bell is selling chicken
wings he's like it's in revelations
people talking about how the world is
ending
just incredible yeah
the lie versus the truth yeah
lottie
but they'll tell you the truth yeah
but just like there was just a repeat of
like
those kinds of things of like
so
i feel like he definitely stuck on the
theme of like world war three of just
like this war of what to believe what
not to believe lie versus the truth
um
like
good
uh what was it it was
or something hold on
did your camera just move oh okay yeah
yeah yeah
um
oh yeah just when you start because he
also brought it back to like god made
chicken
to be
the most like
the greatest animal because in every
culture
everybody eats chicken
and just like how he brought that back
was just so so funny so i felt like he
really kept it to the truth until
the closer like it was like where did
this topic come from
and that was the only thing that took me
off of it was just like this closer i
get it but it felt very club-like and it
was just talking about like
eating
women and i was like come on eating
women even you edited it like it had it
had me clutching my pearls
how far he went and it wasn't just the
closing bit i mean the last like 20
minutes it was it was a good it was a
good solid at least 10 minutes
but even leading up to it like he was
talking about things like it basically
went from like all this very like
really amazing observations with very
unique points of view i mean the war on
drugs not happening anymore because
black people don't make the drugs like
black people don't make fentanyl
you know it's like
like he was making all these incredible
points and observations and then it just
went
south it just went straight to like
literally literally literally south
he eased into with adam and eve's stuff
and then it just kept going south from
there and the fruit and then it just
the cream and i
i finished it
because i love cat and we were doing
this show today but like i was like dang
man i wonder why
not
just do an entire special
like the first half or really the first
40 minutes i mean
i don't know for sure yeah i think was
for me
but that it i and honestly i don't ever
remember cat going like
dirty like that
that was a that felt like a first for me
like in watching kat williams all these
years has he ever gone sort of just like
that graphic
for that long yeah
you have said like i just don't
i don't
see that joke and think
cat williams
and i think that's what kind of took me
out of it i was like man you take you
talking about world war three you're
talking about what's happening in
society you've got all these poignant
points
and now you're gonna end it on a i mean
he ended it on a big [__] joke yeah
that's really what it was yeah yeah like
what are we doing
i know so
that kind of took me out of it
if if he found a way to tie it in like
do do the sex jokes and make it some
sort of analogy to a bigger picture
about society or politics or something
like he did with all these other topics
you know but he literally just went
from all these incredible observations
i'm like wow that's an amazing point and
it's hilarious to then it's just like
sex jokes that you could hear
at any given comedy show you know and i
don't
i don't
like a very it felt like something like
you said
that you didn't think
a proof not i don't want to say a
professional but like yeah a long time
professional
it felt like someone something that
someone found like earlier on in their
career versus something that like a
veteran would be doing it felt like two
different sets like it really
and i love cat and i'm not throwing
shade at all you do whatever you want to
do he sold out a big theater in vegas to
film a netflix special clearly cat's
doing what cat wants to do and it's
working for him but as a comedian
that loves cat williams it's like ah
come on bruh push us across the finish
line i mean he really just
it was just so graphic
here's the thing i think i was okay with
it
until
it just kept going like i think like
okay i get it that's funny like kind of
thing but like
it was
it was a elongated bit like it was a
very long almost like oh no i need to
fill time like
yes
that's what it felt like it felt like i
was like you got your cat williams dude
you got
you're you're hilarious i i mean and
it's not that it wasn't funny right it
just took me out of the mode based on
everything else that i just saw with the
special yeah
yeah yeah i totally agree yeah and
that's what tavis said yeah the end of
the special cut abruptly like he ran out
of time
um
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know so i don't know
it did kind of abruptly end i don't know
like i'd love to ask him about it
um
just to see like
what what what what happened there
yeah yeah yeah i mean
it wasn't the greatest closer that i've
seen from cat because all his closes
have been like
very poignant but also you know what it
was
that closer
didn't close up the entire topic that he
usually talks about and kat is actually
very good at like bringing things back
and i didn't see that with this special
like in all the specials i remember like
he made a big hoopla at the end to bring
back the point that he was making in the
beginning so like just something like
just
i don't even say it was just callbacks
but just something to like
wrap it up
and that didn't feel like a wrap up it
just felt like
here's a
here's a there's a joke
yeah
read it on a truck stop bathroom wall
uh and then here you go
but that being said the special
he still has a lot of hilarious bits in
there still super physical you know he's
like hanging on to the mic stand at one
point like
still his timing like that's something
i think when we talk about earthquake
special and just the amount of laughs
per minute and now he just he does not
take the foot off the gas or as they say
he keep he keep his foot on day neck
as we say in this game
but what i did enjoy about cat's like
performance and his delivery is how
paced it is and he really is just like
building tension
with his pauses and he's in no hurry and
everything's on time and everything has
a purpose i really enjoyed the
performance aspect not only the
physicality but just the confidence and
the pacing of it was really good as well
yeah and i really liked his crowd work
in this one as well like i just loved
how he kept going to the crowd just like
for like quick bits like oh the white
people are nervous right
like and he just kept doing it but it
was so organic it was never
demeaning it was never like it didn't
feel lazy at all it felt like you were
just like that's what i liked about the
whole special was just like it felt
interactive in such a way like let me
tell you all about something that i
think is a little effed up and the dj
yeah he had a few dj queues in there too
yeah yeah and oh yes exactly those dj
kids were on
point and part of that he makes amazing
points about like joe bi like there's
just so many things about the war on
drugs and like politics and then it just
goes
it just goes i don't get it man
i don't get it i don't know why i would
love
i think part of it is just like
that's
maybe it's just that's who cat is maybe
what's the yeah
yeah then someone who's like every once
in a while i got something dirty i want
to say i mean it's kind of like
chappelle does that too he'll say all
these profound things and then like a
silly joke that's dirty just for the
sake of comedy you know so but he kept
going
he kept going
[Laughter]
but
we're gonna start for those of y'all um
for those of y'all that have been
watching us in eclipse lawn care said
he's uh he's watching while mowing he's
listening while mowing so we appreciate
that
um we are gonna start grading comedy
specials
on the earthquake laughter scale
um
so
for this
cat williams
world war three netflix special
yes
what do you give
on a scale of one to five earthquakes
one to five earthquakes i give this
a four earthquakes
a full
i give it a four earthquakes because
everything about this special was great
until the last like 15 minutes of that
bit
like
if i took the entire special those last
like because it was an hour special it
was like 57 minutes it was an hour the
last like 15 minutes i could have done
without so like the rest of it for me
was pretty spectacular
and i got and i understood like
even in the bit
was as dirty as it was i still counted
the laughs
and like there was a lot of laughs in it
so like even though it wasn't like my
speed
it's hard to say that
it wasn't a good performance because the
audience was eating that thing up
like just
all right well
i give it a four yoshi gives it four
earthquakes out of five
um this is so cool
i'm gonna give it and i'd be interested
to know what people think in the the
comments what they would give it but i'm
gonna give it
i'm giving it three out of five here now
i i love cat
he's absolutely hilarious he's been one
of my favorites since i saw pimp and
pimping and since i've been in comedy
he's been kind of a north star for me in
terms of just performance and the
writing that he does but in this one i
mean
the jokes how he ended it it just it
just he made all these amazing points
and then it just got super dirty in the
last quarter of it
and that really took me out of it
because it was such a left turn
and
i get it i get the dj stuff
that it's cool and it's fun and it's
playful and that's what he wanted to do
but that kind of took me out of it i'm
just the purist you know of like when
it's multimedia
and i but i enjoy
i enjoy special effects like
the the special effects when uh
when uh who was it kevin hart had the
toilet
or the toilet yeah
like i enjoy because it feels
three-dimensional it feels like we're
not only talking but there's music
there's like
art like even like and that felt like it
had a purpose but for cats the dj he
could have done without the dj stuff and
um
i don't know for that
and just how it
it just kind of faded out for me
okay that's that's fair that's fair yeah
so i it feels like hot breath it's a
three and a half stars a three and a
half
earthquake we're gonna give we're gonna
give pat williams
three and a half out of five earthquakes
for his new comedy special
this is so cool
chris o'connor said amazing graphics
nice work
thank you so much so if we did three and
a half i don't know how to do it i was
trying to combine them
so three and a half earthquakes out of
five
for mr cat williams
for sure
and what's funny is i forgot to set a
timer for that one so we ran for like 15
minutes but i think it was relevant
yeah it was good
so um what we're gonna start doing
because i know a lot of y'all
uh also come here
just for the joke feedback
and uh we enjoy the topics though too
and some people do so we like to do them
but we want to start doing joke feedback
in between each topic as well and we're
gonna start doing a timer for each topic
i forgot
and then we ran the light like cat did
on his special
so
that being said
[Music]
the first
choke
it was it's just so dirty and it didn't
need to be
so dirty it makes me feel old like
because i'm sure yeah you were watching
it like oh joel is gonna have something
to say about this
yeah yeah i wrote it down i was like
what does joel think about this [__]
i just knew it i just knew it i was like
oh he's gonna be taken out and i was
like okay let's see how long it goes oh
it goes way too long he keeps going
when we talk about expanding a bit he
does a great job of expanding a bit i
will say that
but anyway so let's let's get into some
of y'all jokes y'all jokes here
oh nice
and uh jacob said love the joke feedback
in between topics
yay see we're trying hey each week it's
getting a little bit better and a little
bit better it's just if each week we can
get one percent better then it's gonna
add up to a big difference at the end of
this year when we hit 50 000 subscribers
oh
yeah
so
the first joke i'm seeing here it looks
like it is from zeb
ballentine my guy zeb
so
zeb's joke
i'm a pretty awkward guy i was pretty
nervous when i went on my first date
the girl and i went to dinner and a
movie she had the grilled chicken and i
went to see armageddon
pretty nervous
the girl and i went to dinner in a movie
she had the grilled chicken and i went
to see armageddon
so did he leave her
i guess
i'm gonna be nicer because we just had
brunch together but i saw your wheels
turning of like hmm
where's the joke
yeah so
i think i'm missing the punchline
right
um
[Music]
did you get it
no i mean i think just i can like
connect the dots that he's like oh he
was nervous about the date so he ended
up leaving
um is what i'm assuming but the audience
is gonna be like what
yeah it feels like it's waiting for a
punchline
or the punchline just isn't strong
enough in terms of
it's not clear
what the punchline is in the joke itself
so i do love that it's personalized i
think that's super solid
um
but yeah i think it's just missing
a
a punchy punch line
yeah
yeah zeb says i was so awkward we went
two different things her to dinner and
me to a movie
i think that's i think that's where like
the girl and i went to dinner and a
movie yeah
sounds like
y'all went together so it's confusing
yes and i think he could sum up like
he's like i'm a pretty awkward guy oh i
meant to do a timer for this all right
quick
yeah we'll we're going to do the timer
though because you and i will rant about
this forever um
so um
i think he could just combine it and i
was pretty awkward pretty nervous it's
like i'm bad at dating or i have anxiety
about dating or something's setting up
you're bad at dating
uh
my last date was a we was a dinner and a
movie
she had the grilled chicken and i saw
the movie and armageddon's from like the
90s so he probably needs something a
little more relevant than something
that's on vhs
um
but i like that setup you said dinner
and a movie and she did the dinner and
he did the movie
yeah i yeah i think maybe even
rearranging it like i'm a pretty awkward
guy on dates
last time uh i went on a date
she had
uh grilled chicken and i went to see
armageddon separately like almost like
you mean like you you have to say that
part to get the actual joke itself so
yeah
maybe something to play with
for sure
awesome
okay cool we're back baby
i hope that helped their zeb
yeah hope that helped everybody and
people in the comments were putting in
some um some joke feedback as well for
zeb so i love seeing that
but as we keep it moving here
we are going to set the timer this time
and stick to it
so the next thing up
um samjay
samjay
is having season two of pause
her show on hbo max
um
which i had always heard about i had
seen some clips but i hadn't actually
sat down and watched it until
you told me
it's worth watching and then we can talk
about it and i totally agree um
as a white person it was very
uncomfortable and um
as it should have been you know we
deserve to be uncomfortable but beyond
just the topic she tackles i think just
the overall format of the show is super
unique as well
yeah yeah it's very unique it's very
different and i think like
i mean when you talk about just a
different point of view sam j has a very
different point of view and how she
tackles topics
but her writing is so impeccable
and like the amount of details that she
goes into like there's such nuances like
even in watching her special her
special's actually really solid too
watching her special
the way she talks about different types
of topics
is very nuanced but it's very funny and
intelligent and that's what i really
like about sanjay yeah
yeah that's i think that's a big reason
why you know she got picked up for
season two is because like on the
surface
like you may be like oh it's people
talking about like you know important
topics but like it's coming from such a
unique point of view that i
me as as like a comedian but also as a
white person that would like to be a
better white person
you know um
i think i think it does a lot beyond
just like tackling dope issues that we
need to talk about but also does it in a
super unique way
that's like part podcast part
like
interview interview part man on the
street part sketch like there's so many
different elements that she brings into
it
that um
is really inspiring for comedians of
what they want to create and maybe how
they can start to
rethink the traditional format of like a
a show
yeah you know my favorite part like i
know this is a very small little nuance
thing
i love the fact that sam j has so many
comics
in her show
like it's nothing but comedians in her
show
and then they all get that hbo credit
yes
yeah yeah yeah
i mean and some of them were just like
sitting and chilling and it's like yup i
was on hbo like that right
that's just such a killer like
small little move but like it's almost
like you're building people up to be
like yeah i was on hbo i was on the
episode of sam j pause um but it's like
that's just a cool little like
nugget of
kind of helping people out that i think
it's very dope for comedians to do yeah
i agree and that's that's what we try to
do as well here is like you know give
comics they shine and give them
opportunities where they may otherwise
not get them and it's cool to see
someone at her level doing the same
thing as well absolutely yeah yeah it's
very cool because i've seen like tons of
atlanta comics on there
like you know
but it's just great i think that's just
that's just the dopest thing and now
they get that credit
yeah so check that out it comes out on
may 20th
um when i went to the other screen to be
fancy our timer reset so um but i think
that was about five minutes um
yeah so check it out
so check out sam jay's
yeah season two of paws it's all on
uh hbo max
awesome all right so the next joke we
have here
is from gary bachman
all right
two of the people i appreciate most are
my barber and my broker they both do
great jobs with so little work with so
little to work with
both do great jobs with so little to
work with
okay
um
i get it but i feel like it needs more
context it's like missing some level of
context
around
with so little work with are you trying
to say you don't have any money or you
don't have any hair
then i think you almost have to say that
yeah that's what it seems like
the clever like it feels more clever
than clear
and it's maybe it's like the punchline
is the barber and broker and not the
setup so maybe it's like
i always appreciate people who do jobs
with little
to work with
that's why i
appreciate my barber and broker or
something and really it could just be
barber or broker like you could really
just keep it to one of them just for the
sake of like a punch line and have more
punch to it than just two words
yeah
yeah because i feel like yeah when you
have the two words then you gotta find
something that brings both of those
things together
but if it's
like something little to work with you
gotta define what that little to work
with is
like
so i almost feel like i'm bold
and i don't make a lot of money
so the two people i appreciate is my
barber and my broker because they do
great stuff with so little to work with
yeah
yeah cool well hope that helps there
gary
we helped helped you tighten it up there
a little bit my friend
tight
toit
and speaking of toit
we got it we got it we got a toy topic
coming up next and i i threw this one in
on us at the last minute
uh because i saw a clip of
chris d stefano and bert kreischer who
still has not been on the show uh
despite saying he would
um
but you know what is he doing like
touring forever like what is he doing
working making millions of dollars
instead of coming on hot breath
um
he's selling out red rocks and i'm like
yo bert you need the hot breath bump
buddy um
but he said he would do it
so
but
that being said you and i are both
uh married comedians you have children i
have a dog so we're basically the same
essentially the same
essentially yep but something that came
up with uh bert kreischer
and christy stefano talking
on their podcast this week they were on
two bears one cave
and this really just struck me so i
really wanted to share this with you and
the hot breath the verse
and um really just kind of
discuss this topic for a few minutes
just on the relevance of balancing
family life
and life of being a comedian on the road
and seeing someone like chris d stefano
who just dropped a netflix special by
the way selling out theaters by the way
and yet this is where he is at in his
career after grinding for years and
years and years to get to this point
this
is where he is now
of everything has been for me so far is
like i've missed every single one of my
daughter's swim meets
and i'm like
[__] you know like yeah i just made
sick a lot of money and i'm like but
i've i watch i've been watching my
daughter's life on like a phone
and it's a little like wow this is crazy
it's happening
it's a little like what am i doing like
she's never going to be six again you
know and i miss like tons of her life
what the what the price
yeah so
yeah and then that clip goes on for like
a while and then oh
as well so like it's it becomes it my
favorite part is that it's two men
showing vulnerability about a very tough
topic
that is
doesn't get talked about a lot
especially not in comedy right um
but i think you know it's it's the
reality of what do you do for your
dreams like what do you do to
make
your you know this thing that you've
always wanted to do happen and yeah also
realizing okay this is this is the
sacrifice to get there
um
and this is what i've given up
but it's also a nice little like gut
check
was this worth it like was this thing
that i've given up
worth it to make it happen to be where i
want to be today
yeah and it really gave me some
pause to like well what do i what is my
what does the future of my career look
like like do i want to be at a place
like where chris is right now where it's
like oh he quote made it and i already
feel like i made it but like you know
he's he's hitting that next tax bracket
of comedy now and he's like
oh my what am i doing
yeah i mean i think
i think as you get older
and as you like
are grinding it out in
the in any really any kind of
business or any kind of like pursuit
that you have
like you recognize that
all these other things are still
happening
you still got a family you still got a
wife you still got a marriage you still
got to be a dad all these things still
happen
just because you're killing it you know
at a at a show in florida for the
weekend
you're still a dad you mean like you're
still
and so i mean i think i
i've recognized i try not to miss those
moments because those moments are way
more important for me
than
the glitz and glamour of comedy but have
i missed a moment where i was just like
hey uh i've missed a birthday i wasn't
happy about it for comedy
yeah i've missed a birthday for comedy
because i wasn't happy about it um for a
show um
and i was yeah it was not fun
i mean i'm about to miss i'm missing my
wife's birthday tomorrow
for to do comedy yeah
like
i also prepped i was like yo
i'm doing this like it was like months
in advance and so like yeah i don't feel
great about it but it's also
understanding from the other side like
oh i appreciate it we're gonna try to
you know
it's a day but also let's make sure that
we at least connect and have a good time
beforehand um
to make sure it doesn't feel like
completely that i'm out of the picture
so yeah i mean i think
i don't know any comedian that hasn't
had to have made that kind of sacrifice
for this life though
yeah i'm always like
i'm i'm more mindful than ever of
that balance and also of like what is
worth doing and what isn't
and
um and when you when i am with family
it's like i'm a hundred percent there
like even just like
if i if the amount of time
isn't as much as i want it to be
but i can make that quality time i can
make the quality of the time better
which can make up for that lack of like
the amount of time can make up for the
quality of time so i'm 100 there
and
i think something we've talked about
before as married comedians is like that
transparency around just checking in
with your spouse i'm about to be gone
for four weekends in a row is this cool
like how do you feel about this or
like this is kind of the direction my
career is headed but here's why i'm
doing certain things like keeping them
a part of your career and yeah part of
the journey yeah exactly yeah like it's
that open honest communication because i
remember there was a time when i was
doing like a lot of open mics i was just
like babe i need to get up four to five
times a week
and i was and it was affecting
everything
and then
i sat down and i was like yo uh
and she was like we'll need you to cut
this time down because you were not here
my bad
because you know at the end of the day
it's like yeah i want to be here like
and i want to do the things that i want
to do so yeah and so then we just
adjusted the schedule and be like all
right i'm gonna do two nights but on
those two nights i'm out pretty much all
night i'm trying to do two to three mics
a night for every night rather than
trying to do like five nights a week
and yeah i was very conscious and know
that
i'm not
a you know i'm at seven years now i'm
not a seven year comedian that's been
going up seven nights a week you know
i'm saying like
i i know that that out those hours
haven't been put in in that way so the
hours that i have put in i'm exactly
where i need to be you mean like i can't
go out seven nights a week but i go up
two nights a week
and that is where my comedy is
and like you like we said quality of
time with family you make sure that the
quality of time you spend with your
comedy is also higher quality so
you are doing as m if you do go out
you're doing as many shows as possible
you're making the most of those
opportunities you're preparing for your
set you're doing the best you can on
your set you're
networking you're really moving your
career forward so quality of time with
family but then also balancing that
making sure you make the most of the
time you do when you're working on your
comedy and it'll just add up to make a
bigger difference
facts
facts yep but yeah i think it's a
constant struggle though i think it's
one of those things that it's never
gonna be like an answer on i mean and
you know
women deal with this all the time
comics deal with this all the time
people who have dreams
will always be dealing with
how do i balance my dream versus
my reality of having responsibility
that's that's pretty much the definition
of life
yeah
yeah it's all about balance my friends
balance baby
speaking of which we are balancing it
out with another joke here
uh looks like the next joke is from
tavis
see tavis aikman
let me see here mink consumed porn
like we're at the buffet like if you
catch us watching porn and say i didn't
know you would like that
i don't then why do you have it it was
there
like this i think it's got
it might need a little bit of
clarification
to where i think it feels like there's
two people having a conversation
and you need to be
like clear about
the two people so
rather than saying man consume like it's
so generalized just be like my best
friend and i consume porn like a buffet
you mean like almost like personalize it
so it doesn't feel so general
and then sort of you can go back and
forth he says this or i say this or
compare it to like
either your relationship like either my
wife and i
um
have different points or have different
views on this
i consume it this way you mean so like
there's just
too many words at the moment
yeah and as we were talking about family
my wife was texting me so i was just um
um
cool
but um
yeah
so it was about quality time i was
putting my quality time into this text
message and not tavis's joke
but um
ahmed said didn't start the timer oh
there we go we're getting better
all right
the show gets better and better a little
bit a little bit every single
uh
every single week here but um
yeah i like the analogy of men consume
porn like a buffet
i think it could just be personal
i consume
porn like i'm at a buffet so now it's a
little more personal there
um
like if my why my wife caught me
watching porn
i'd say then this quote which the quote
i didn't quite i wasn't following all of
it i probably need to hear him deliver
it for it to really register it's like
it's the other person saying i didn't
know you like this but it's not clear
based on that so it's like all the
person's saying i didn't know you like
this or i don't then why do you have it
on it was there so it's almost like this
back and forth oh okay it's a back and
forth okay yeah
yes
okay so you don't have to introduce that
character oh and jacob said it's a back
and forth as well i guess everyone knew
but me probably because i was texting my
wife
uh
but honestly like
it would be great to be more specific oh
and we're out of time but it's kind of
like we're talking it's and whatnot but
a lot of humor comes in specificity so
i'm sure there's something
in a buffet that could also maybe be
mistaken for porn
like the the general sows gang bang
chicken or something like
you know
something like that
[Laughter]
oh my heavens
we're just about how cat williams got
dirty and then i just said that
general sal
gang bang chicken
i'm gonna order that
on uber eats
don't let your wife catch you
[Laughter]
all right
i feel like you get dirtier just being
around me for sure for sure
bad influence
but
my wife was texting me if we were ending
right at six so we're gonna go over a
few minutes for your joke feedback but
let's let's move let's move right into
our final
our final topic here we do and this is
flowers this is a new segment we want to
do is we talked about sam jay doing
um given shine to other comedians on her
show that's what we want to do here
and we want to give people they flowers
on here so every week you know as we are
working comedians out there on the grind
we want to shout out
uh people or scenes last week i shouted
out the richmond comedy scene how nice
they were to me
but this week
i would like to give my flowers
to actually
hot breath og
john molehill okay
john molehill
started
pj
pj are our lost
i'm not applauding pj's death let me let
that applause zimmer down it's like our
our friend of hot breath that we lost
and there's applause happening
but um he actually just like a pj was a
member of the hot breath verse still is
and um he created the memes
for our right ten club we do every day
in our facebook group where we get a new
word write a new joke and the winner
gets a meme
when pj passed john took on that role of
creating a meme every single day and
that is a lot of work
and he just recently posted in the group
like yo i've been doing this over a year
i gotta stop
and i totally understand that's why pj
took it over from me because i was like
yo i gotta stop so to do it every single
day
i want to give flowers to john for doing
that for over a year every single day so
shout out to john mulhill
i'm giving john the flowers and now
evelyn metcalf is taking over that daily
meme uh creation so um
give a rose to uh evelyn as well there
but um
there's my flowers for this week john
mulhill what you got yoshi
um i'm gonna give my flowers to uh
not an individual person but a concept
that i've seen
in the scene lately
i'm in atlanta but it happens all over
uh where people when they're coming to
the city you can hit up uh like a
facebook group that basically says i'm
coming to atlanta i've seen it in
nashville i've seen it in denver i've
seen in california and then people will
just be like yo drop a video and if i
like what i see i'd put you up on the
show i think that's like the most
supportive thing that you can do and
just seeing that especially like in the
summer because i think somehow people
have a bit more time and they're
traveling more willing to travel so just
doing that just across the scene across
the country is like just the coolest
thing so just
a big big off bouquet of flowers to
everyone who credit them i'm coming into
the fitting up in comics from out of
town get up uh so i do that too so if i
have a show and a comic's coming in town
i'll go look on that page be like yo
come to the show i've done that a couple
of times for shows and then people have
returned not even return the favor
i've gone to other cities and they'll
just put me up on the show just for you
know linking up and so i think it's just
the coolest thing ever just you know as
we say you're going to get the most
shine and the most amount of work likely
from other comedians yep for sure it's
the way the business works
so uh knowing that there's people out
there just helping out that's what i
want to give flowers to boom
uh yeah i love those groups too
it's always good seeing comics helping
comics out there
oh i love it yeah and people are saying
thank you john gary said way to go john
and
jones said thank you or yay john and
thank you evelyn and gary thank you john
i love that yeah i love love seeing the
love
so
in the next in the last few minutes here
if there's other jokes that we missed we
are doing the timer the timer's already
up i remember this time
this time
he must be a um
so
it looks like the next joke i'm seeing i
think it's actually from our buddy
jeff cohn
okay jeff cone here did i read the last
one
yeah you read the last one all right
being an adoptee affects my dating
i was out with this woman she reminded
me of my birth mom because i knew i
wouldn't be going home with her
oh
okay
is that what this woman came out of my
birth mom
that's good
i like how personal it is too
yeah like we're learning a lot about
jeff in a short amount of time
yeah
i like that i don't i don't hate it
that's pretty solid
i mean i think you could probably cut
down the words
um
just like she reminded me of my birth
mom
i knew i wouldn't be going home with her
like
you mean like there's just elements that
you could cut down in terms of just
lesser words but that's like two words
that you took out but i like it i like
the joke i like the setup i like how
personal it is and it'd be fun to see
this see jeff do this on stage i'm a
very
direct kind of comedian so i can see
this being like kill
if for the editing i think it would be
interesting to see
at the end of it
um it's like being an adoptee affects my
dating every woman reminds me of my
birth mom because i know i won't be
going home with her so now it just cuts
it down to just like
saying the same thing but a lot quicker
for sure yeah and now it's more
generalized but it's about your dating
life
oh that's good uh yeah oh and jeff yeah
jeff said thank you i want to go deep on
that topic too great trim yoshi i'll try
it that way we'll try it my way too now
he's gonna he's gonna be doing
earthquake edits all right how are these
joke edits how many earthquakes
are these joke addicts worth
but beautiful i love that joke man i i
always love
hearing um like super personal jokes
where you're learning a lot about the
person
and that's uniquely to them so the
adoptee and all and dating and all
that's just super unique and personal
and gary said good one jeff look at all
the love in here today
yeah it's solid that's funny
uh the next joke i'm seeing here is from
steve
polger
uh there are many guides that call
themselves a bible i was reading the
grilling bible and expected them to say
if you use the oven you're going to hell
um
that's funny
i think
uh
i like this joke i don't think you need
the expected them to say i just say you
say it
i was reading the grilling bible and it
said if you use the oven you're going to
hell yeah
i love that
don't make it a hypothetical just say it
because that's funny
yeah
i totally that's a great edit there
so many guys that call themselves the
bible i was reading the grilling bible
expecting them to say if you use the
oven you're going to hell yeah
i was reading the grilling bible and it
said if you use the oven you're going to
hell
yeah
that's it
yeah i don't really have any i think
that's the edit i don't really have
anything else for that one
yeah
nice job there steve
seconds noise i love that
nice steve's here consistently you know
and it's paying off
nicely done there steve
uh the next one oh from bobby
sorry i'm late was busy with the other
comedy endeavors the depp heard trial is
insane
[Laughter]
i know i haven't looked at it that much
but
instead of endeavors i think i was
watching
a new comedy sitcom or a new comedy show
something a little more specific
endeavors is a little bit vague
yeah but
otherwise i like it i think the mystery
x there if we just change endeavors to
something more like a show or comedy
sitcom commerce sketch show or something
you know
yeah true crime comedy you know
something like that maybe
or just a new reality tv show yeah
yeah yeah that's a good
point yeah i like that
oh very nice there bobby
thanks for thanks for squeezing in here
i love it
oh yeah and she made a comment about we
were talking about families she didn't
get back into comedy until her youngest
was 16.
he was special needs and in society if a
woman is at home
because she's following her unpaid dream
she's a monster
well it's it's like it's like how the
joke doctor
he became the joke doctor
because he ended up taking custody of
his son his son wanted to live with him
he was on the road like 40 something
weeks a year he was a working touring
comic and he changed all that to take
care of his family so um
it's just yeah it's it's it's incredible
[Music]
this is jacob osbourne
you want me to read this one
yeah go ahead being an american is
having a government that gets pissed at
any non-corporate growth that's why we
bomb mountains
ah
speaking of family yoshi is talking to
his family right now so we we may need
to land this plane here
but
government that gets pissed any
non-corporate growth that's why we bomb
mountains
i just don't get the bombing mountains
part
where are we bombing
mountains oh because corporate growth
looks like a mountain
is that i think that's what it is oh i
thought he was saying because
a mountain isn't corporate growth it's
like like a natural growth
hmm
i don't know
being an american is having
being an american is having a government
that gets pissed at any non-corporate
growth that's why we bomb mountains
joel got it said jacob okay i just don't
know us bombing mountains i think we
need something
else that we bomb
that
um
maybe it's a little more
relevant i just don't know about us
bombing mountains you know
yeah
because mountains
yeah this feels like a bombing joke so
yoshi's getting sassy y'all getting
sassy
i think i just don't get the i don't get
the transition to the punchline
yeah he was saying um bombing in the
middle east is where the mountains are
so i think it would be that's why we
bombed the middle east or something
because they don't have any corporate
growth or that's why we bomb
poor countries because they don't have
corporate growth so something a little
more specific
than like bombing mountains a little
more vague so maybe like poor countries
would work there
for sure and maybe i just don't get the
non-corporate growth part
like i don't get what that means
just those three words together i have
no idea what that means
yeah he's just trying to sound smart
he's just watched a podcast right
that's like non-corporate growth man
that's
we bombing them
yo ricardo
let's uh let's get ricardo's in here and
then we can land the plane
uh
sleep is like sex for me i need pills to
get it going
i can't ever find that sweet spot and
most of the time my phone goes off
before me
i get it i get it it's kind of silly
that it's your phone that is that you're
having sex with so
yeah i like the analogy sleep is like
sex for me
um and he's going for a power of threes
here i think it could just be tighter
though like
yeah i don't even think i need the pills
to get it going part as needed
i never find the sweet spot most of the
time my phone goes off before me
i wonder if that's it though like sleep
is like sex for me
most of the time my phone finishes
before me or my phone goes off before me
oh that's good and just go right to that
i think because a lot of times comics
will hear a power of threes and feel
like they need to shoehorn it into every
single joke but sometimes for word
economy
it's just
what is the punch line and not try to
overwrite it
yeah i like that nice
oh yeah ricardo agrees
yeah
i didn't see a meds joke
he said
can we get his joke i don't see his joke
i didn't see it either
yeah i don't know
can you rewrite it on that
it may have gotten flagged
um
on youtube i'll have to go to the actual
youtube to see
oh he did write a joke about advice on
making race jokes
he said black don't crack but it does
die from high blood pressure
oh boy
i think like that's one of those things
you should do in front of a crowd
yeah see how they react and then you'll
let they'll let you know
if that's an okay joke to do
good point yeah and what i've found with
all race jokes is it's got to be
um authentic to you
yes you can't just go into it and you
can't just say it just for the sake of
saying right
yeah the
kind of perspective
cool
yeah yeah so i hope that helps answer
your question there on med
and um as we land this plane here i mean
thank y'all so much for
hanging out with us today
all we ask please subscribe to this
youtube channel we're trying to hit 50
000 subscribers this year
and let peeps know share this video
right now as you're watching this
hit share
and spread the comedy love
and we're gonna change the game one
comic at a time so
that is it
we're landing this plane my friends
landed it
we love you all so much
angel's on y'all
we'll see y'all next week
bye y'all